thanks to surf shark for sponsoring this
video
find out more later in the video hey
42 here henrietta lacks was born
in roanoke virginia in 1920
just two days after women were given the
right to vote in the united states
hers wasn't an easy life her mother
died giving birth to a tenth child when
henrietta was just four years old
and her father unable to cope with such
a large family on his own
divided his children out amongst
whichever relatives
were prepared to take them henrietta was
working out in the local tobacco fields
from an age
that would be illegal today and she
dropped out of school in the sixth grade
to help support her family full time
she had her first child at 14 and four
more would arrive over the following
15 years tragically at the age of just
henrietta passed away she had lived a
short
hard life and for many years her name
was forgotten to all but those who were
closest to her
her friends and family but little did
they know
that henrietta lacks hadn't really died
at
all at least not exactly and
what was more in the years since her
non-death
this unassuming woman had been busy
changing the world playing a pivotal
role
in some of the most important
breakthroughs in medical science
of the entire 20th century you see
whilst henrietta may have lived a pretty
unremarkable life
she most certainly wasn't your average
woman
in fact henrietta lacks was immortal
sort of if you love traveling
then you'll love the fastest and easiest
vpn
surf shark did you know surf shark helps
you to avoid price discrimination
based on your location so you can save
money on plane tickets and car rentals
whilst traveling surfshard runs on any
device
anywhere and it's packed full of
features
such as industry-leading uncrackable
encryption
ip and dns leak protection an internet
kill switch if your vpn drops out and 24
7 customer support
personally i use surf shock to watch
netflix content from other countries
such as the us that's usually blocked
here in the uk
surf shock maintains a strict no logs
policy and their network of 3200
servers in over 65 countries runs
completely on ram
so they couldn't even log your data even
if they wanted to
by using the code 42 you will benefit
from an 83 percent discount
plus free extra months for free all you
have to do
is click the special link in the
description below
don't miss it to tell this strange tale
it's probably best if we start at the
beginning of the end
of henrietta's life that is back in
early 1951 when she was 30 years old
henrietta felt what she described as a
knot
in her womb she'd already had four
children by this point
and her family suspected the feeling of
discomfort
was the first sign that baby number five
was on the way as it happened
they were right but after giving birth
to a son the unsettling feeling in
henrietta's belly
didn't go away which is how
soon afterwards she found herself
sitting in the waiting room
at johns hopkins the only hospital in
the area that would treat black patients
henrietta was seen by howard jones who
in later life would go on to establish a
reproduction
center responsible for the world's first
so-called test tube baby but at the time
he was a young doctor
at the start of his career during his
examination
dr jones dr jones calling
sorry i got carried away there
discovered a strange mass of bleeding
tissue
unlike cervix unlike anything he'd seen
before
he took a biopsy for testing and when
the results came back
they were unequivocal henrietta lacks
had cervical cancer she was treated with
radium tube
inserts which are exactly what they
sound like
but the cancer was so aggressive it
continued to grow and spread faster than
radiation could kill it
before the year was out henrietta had
passed away
but during her treatment unbeknownst to
henrietta herself
two further tissue samples were taken
from her cervix
one of healthy cells the other cancerous
these were sent to johns hopkins cell
biologist
george otto gay head of the hospital's
tissue culture laboratory
and it was in dr gay's lab that
something truly remarkable happened gay
had been trying to culture cervical
cancer cells for years
when henrietta's samples arrived on his
desk and
he knew the challenges involved better
than anyone even inside our own bodies
human cells only go through so many
divisions
usually between 40 and 60. before
cell division ceases for a phenomenon
known as senescence
this cap on the number of times a cell
can divide
is known as the hayflick limit in his
lab
even if dr gay created just the right
conditions
he was lucky if he could coax more than
a handful of generations of cell
divisions
out of his cultured samples before long
no matter what he tried
the cells would die and he'd need to
find a new sample to work with
at least that's how things usually went
it soon became clear that henrietta's
cells
were different because far from dying
out in his carefully constructed
cultures
the cancer cells taken from henrietta's
cervix
thrived dividing over and over again
long after they should have perished and
that led dr gay to a rather startling
conclusion
henrietta lacks cells were immortal
this discovery was a big deal
like a very big deal you see an immortal
cell line
one where the cells continue to divide
over and over again
apparently forever offered researchers
something they'd never had before
an unlimited supply of uniform genuine
human tissue
that was cheap to produce on mass in a
lab
and could be used to carry out all
manner of experiments
such a cell line would eliminate the
need to laboriously collect tissue
samples from patients
and since the cells could be cultured in
a lab
there was none of the ethical concerns
that might have been associated
with testing gun tissue that was still
attached to the human
who'd made it possible in the first
place by the way i should point out that
in the human body
cancer cells aren't affected by the
hayflick limit
they can continue dividing over and over
again
though this wasn't understood until the
60s
and anyway outside the body in an
artificial culture
it's a very different story and much
like regular cells
cultured cancer cells soon die out
but for some reason henrietta lacks
didn't and it was a game changer for
biological research
dr gaine knew exactly how important this
discovery was
and so he began handing out the cells
which
he dubbed healer after the woman they
came from
to anyone who wanted them in the hopes
they would be used to make breakthroughs
in many areas of medical science and
it wasn't long before hela cells
were doing exactly that in 1953
it was found that healer cells could be
reliably infected with polio
one of the world's most feared childhood
diseases
allowing scientists to study the disease
at scale
for the first time in history which
directly led to the development of the
world's first
polio vaccine taming polio was one of
the first scientific breakthroughs made
using healer cells but there have been
so many
since there's no way i could possibly
list them all in this video
healer cells have been used to study the
effects of radiation on human tissue
they were blasted into space on some of
the very first rockets to investigate
the impact space travel might have on
our bodies
they were crucial to the development of
ivf
and they have been vital tools in the
research of a whole host of different
viruses
including hiv hpv zika herpes
measles mumps and yes even covid
the cultured cells of henrietta lacks
were the first
ever mass-produced human cells and
the first to be cloned they have been
central to the establishment of more
than 11 000
patents the writing of more than 100
000 scientific papers and the winning
of at least five nobel prizes by
some estimations over 20 tons of
healer cells have been created over the
years
and they're still going strong to this
day
70 years after henrietta died
it's no exaggeration to say that healer
cells
have changed the world as we know it
and saved innumerable lives in the
process
all of which is pretty incredible i'm
sure you'll agree
but there's another side to this
remarkable story
one that's rather less rosy and a whole
lot more complicated
you may remember i mentioned earlier in
the video that tissue from henrietta's
cervix was taken
without her knowledge or consent before
being sent
to george otto gay's human tissue
culture lab
at john hopkins hospital which when you
think about it is
a little concerning i mean healer cells
were fueling research
all over the world and yet henrietta's
relatives
had absolutely no idea that the living
tissue of their nearest
and dearest was being used and
you could say abused in this way it
would be some
25 years before they found out
in the meantime their lives have been
going on pretty much as they always had
been
the unsavory irony here is
that whilst henrietta lacked cells were
enabling medical research that would go
on to make farmer corporations
millions perhaps billions of dollars
members of her own family didn't even
have enough money
to pay for basic medical care i should
point out that
no crime was committed here or at least
nothing more than a
moral crime the doctors of johns hopkins
hospital were under no legal obligation
to ask for permission to take
henrietta's cells
and no companies or individuals who made
money from their work with healer cells
owed the family a penny by the letter of
the law
taking human tissue samples without
consent
was completely standard procedure at the
time and even today
material obtained from a patient during
surgery
blood and tissue samples say can be used
for research
in much the same way henrietta's was i'm
sorry to tell you that in the relatively
unlikely event
money is made using your bits and pieces
after surgery
you aren't entitled to any of it
this was actually tested in the
california supreme court back in 1990
when a man named john moore who suffered
from leukemia
discovered his cells had been turned
into an immortal cell line
much like healer and later
commercialized by his physician
unsurprisingly moore wanted a slice of
the very big pie
but the court ruled on the side of the
physician making it clear
that an individual has no rights to his
own discarded cells
and no right to any profits that may
later be gained from them
intuitively it feels wrong that
our own cells could be used in this way
without our permission
for the profits of others but is it just
as easy as saying
we should have to give express
permission in order for someone to use
our body parts for research
your reflex answer to that question may
well be
a resounding yes so was mine
but is it really that simple what if
scientists came across a person whose
cells had some
unique property we could use to cure
cancer
let's say enabling research that may
save
millions upon millions of lives
if that individual happened to be a bit
of an
who quite like the idea of sticking two
fingers up at the rest of humanity
by refusing to let scientists get their
latex gloved hands on his valuable cells
should he be allowed to do so admittedly
it's hard to say how realistic that
scenario might be
but it certainly gets you thinking then
there's the fact that the more
bureaucracy you add to a process like
obtaining human tissue for research
the more time it's going to take
something that poses a bit of a problem
since living human tissue has
unsurprisingly
quite a short shelf life add too much
red
tape or seek too many approvals
and we might risk missing out on making
medical breakthroughs
that could save lives as is often the
case with complex moral conundrums
there really are no easy answers here
though i think pretty much everyone
would agree it's
wrong that henrietta lacks family were
left living in poverty
whilst her cells were busy changing the
world and making
others very rich in the process so
clearly something needs to change hela
was the world's first immortal cell line
and to this day it remains the most
important
and the most widely used cell line in
biological research
healer is no longer unique many other
immortal cell lines have been developed
since
but it's still very much remarkable
henrietta lacks
cervical cancer cells are so robust
and grow so aggressively that they're
able to easily
out-compete most other cells even other
immortal cell lines
and in the 70s scientists began to
realize that many cultures of
what they thought were immortal cells
from other lines
had in fact been taken over by
rogue healer cells cross-contamination
of cultures
is incredibly hard to prevent we're
talking about human cells here
objects so tiny they can happily float
from place to place
on a moat of dust and healer is so
hardy so fast growing and downright
dominant if just a few cells drift into
a nearby culture
more often than not they soon take over
remarkably it's estimated 20 to 30
percent
of all immortal cell lines have been
contaminated by
healer cells and that's more than a
minor
inconvenience it essentially invalidates
every experiment conducted with the
contaminated cell cultures
and since most researchers traditionally
haven't tested the identity or purity of
the cell lines they're working with
we're talking about a vast amount of
research
that's being called into question in
stories
told by those who knew her in life
henrietta lacks was a fun-loving
caring mother who found happiness
despite the hardships she faced
in death she unwittingly became
one of the most influential people ever
to have lived
hers is a story that mixes tragedy and
triumph but none of that takes away from
the truly monumental impact
this unassuming woman has had
on the modern world henrietta lacks may
have
lost her life to cancer but in a strange
twist of fate
that very same cancer made her immortal
and changed biological research forever
thanks for watching check out my new
podcast
random interesting facts available on
youtube spotify
apple podcast and anywhere else you get
your podcasts
link in the description below thanks